Vamos a hacer
unos cuantos problemas que traigan
juntos los conceptos
que aprendimos en los últimos vídeos,
así que digamos que tenemos
la siguiente desigualdad, que es,
4x más 3 es menor que -1
¿Ok?
Tenemos 4x más 3 menor que -1
y lo primero
que se me ocurre para ir
encontrando todas las "x"
que satisfacen esta desigualdad,
eso es lo que queremos realmente hacer,
pues es primero quitar este 3 que me está estorbando
¿verdad?
¿Y cómo lo quitamos?
Pues qué tal si restamos
3 de ambos lados
¿Ok? Restamos 3 de ambos lados desigualdad,
de esta desigualdad y
al final de cuentas cuando
uno resta números de una desigualdad,
pues no pasa nada con el...
con el signo de la desigualdad,
se queda igual,
entonces,
estos se cancelan
y simplemente de este lado me queda
4x que es menor que -1 menos 3
que es -4, muy bien,
Entonces ahora para quitarme
este 4 que me está estorbando de mi "x",
pues puedo dividir entre 4,
dividimos ambos lados
entre 4
y aquí,
como dividimos entre un número positivo
recordemos que la desigualdad
solo se cambia de sentido
cuando multiplicamos
o dividimos por un número negativo,
por ejemplo, si multiplicas por -1,- 1/2, -10
¿Qué sé yo?
Pero aquí estamos dividiendo
entre un número positivo que es 4,
así que no pasa nada,
no le afecta en nada
y esto me dice que queda "x"
porque estos se cancelan,
es menor que -4 entre 4
que es
-1
y esto ya es nuestro conjunto solución,
ahora que si lo quieres ver
en términos de intervalos, pues,
partimos del -1 y no lo incluimos
¿verdad?
aquí no nos está diciendo que lo incluyamos
y nos vamos para abajo,
todo para abajo
hasta llegar al menos infinito...
ok, legamos a menos infinito
y esta es nuestra anotación
¿verdad?
El paréntesis significa
que no estamos incluyendo a -1
y por supuesto al menos infinito no lo podemos incluir, porque no es un número, entonces,
esta es nuestra solución
en términos de intervalos.
Vamos a ver otro ejemplito
un poco más difícil,
digamos que tengo 5x
más grande que 8x más 27...
más 27,
entonces, nuevamente
queremos de alguna forma
ir despejando la "x"
entonces,
¿qué tal si este 8x lo pasamos del otro lado restando?
es decir, ¿qué pasaría
si yo resto 8x de ambos lados?
si yo resto 8x de ambos lados,
entonces,
lo que me queda de este lado son
5x -8x que son -3x
y de este lado,
pues estos se cancelan y me queda aquí el 27,
este 27 de aquí.
Ahora la desigualdad realmente tampoco cambia
porque no estamos multiplicando
o dividiendo ¿verdad?
simplemente pues restamos un número
y eso no afecta en nada,
y entonces se queda el,
el signo mayor que.
Ahora bien queremos despejar la "x",
nuevamente, pues
¿Qué podemos hacer?
Dividir todo entre -3
y si dividimos todo entre -3,
ahora sí notemos
que estamos dividiendo entre un número negativo,
en este caso,
si se invierte la desigualdad
¿Ok?
entonces tenemos -3x
dividido entre - 3
va a estar relacionado,
ahorita vemos cómo
con 27 entre -3
y como dijimos que
dividimos entre un número negativo,
este mayor que,
pues ya no va a ser mayor que,
ahora se invierte, se voltea ¿verdad?
Se invierte y ahora es un menor que.
Realmente la forma en que yo me acuerdo
de qué significan estos simbolitos,
es que por ejemplo,
la parte que está más abierta
digamos esta apertura,
es el que indica al número más grande
¿no? Puede ser, no sé...
pensar como,
que
esta es la mayor altura que hay
en éste, en este simbolito
y acá está la menor altura,
¿verdad?
Espero eso no te confunda,
es la forma en que yo me acuerdo, y espero te sirva
pero bueno,
si seguimos esto,
esto se cancela y me queda
que "x" es más chico que
27 entre -3
que eso no es otra cosa más que
-9
¿ok?
Entonces nuevamente,
si uno quisiera expresarlo en términos de
intervalos,
pues tengo -9
que no lo incluyo,
por eso pongo el paréntesis
y me voy hacia abajo
hasta menos infinito,
muy bien.
Vamos a divertirnos un poco
con la línea real
¿Qué pasa si yo quiero graficar mi resultado?
Pues por ejemplo podemos pensar
que aquí anda el  -9,
acá anda el -8,
acá anda el -10
y lo que dice es,
tómate
todos los más chicos que -9,
pero a - 9 no lo incluyas,
entonces ponemos una bolita
y nos tomamos,
todos los más chicos que -9
y ponemos la bolita sin rellenar,
porque no lo estamos incluyendo, ¿verdad?
¡Muy bien!
Muy bien hasta ahí.
Vamos ahora a hacer un ejemplo
un poco más complicado,
un poco más enredado
¿Muy bien?
Por ejemplo
éste que tengo aquí,
que es
8x menos 5 veces 4x más 1
es mayor o igual que
-1 más 2 veces 4x menos 3
¡Muy bien!
Entonces yo sé que esto puede parecer aterrador
que quizás ya te ya te dio miedo, pero,
realmente no es muy distinto
a los que hemos hecho anteriormente,
solo hay que simplificar estas expresiones
y verás que llegamos a cosas muy similares.
Entonces eso es lo que vamos a hacer,
vamos a distribuir estos productos
y tenemos aquí 8x,
¿y quién es - 5 por 4x?
eso es -20x
y ahora -5 por 1
es -5,
esta desigualdad,
pues realmente no estamos haciendo nada
más que simplificar,
así que se queda igual
y esto es
mayor o igual que -1
y ahora hacemos 2 por 4x son
8x y 2 por -3 es -6
¿Ok?
muy bien,
entonces,
esto realmente
ya es mucho más amigable,
lo que tenemos que hacer pues...
por ejemplo podemos
agrupar estos términos
del lado izquierdo.
¿Cuánto será 8x menos 20x?
Pues eso en realidad es
-12x ¿verdad?
Hacemos la resta y le dejamos el signo del más grande.
Entonces, esto es 12x,
el -5 se queda igual
y esto es mayor o igual...
y aquí,
¿qué es lo que podemos hacer?
Podemos agrupar los términos constantes
y tenemos -1 menos 6
es -7
al cual
le estamos sumando 8x,
¡Muy bien!... muy bien,
entonces si queremos dejar
las "x" todas del lado izquierdo
pues lo que nos conviene es restar
8x de ambos lados ¿verdad?
Para que aquí se cancele,
entonces restamos 8x
de este lado
y restamos 8x de este lado,
¿Qué es lo que me queda del lado izquierdo?
Pues -12x menos 8x
son -20x,
este -5 se queda igual,
el signo realmente no cambia,
sólo estamos restando,
así que esto
va a ser mayor o igual que
-7 y estos se cancelan
¡Muy bien!... muy bien.
Entonces para seguir despejando la "x"
ahora vamos a sumar
5 de ambos lados,
para quitar este 5 de aquí
que nos está estorbando,
entonces
si sumamos 5 de ambos lados,
esto se cancela,
esto me queda -20x...
-20x
que es mayor o igual...
es mayor o igual,
¿que quién es esta suma?
-7 más 5 es -2...
-7 más 5 es -2
¡Muy bien!
Ahora sí vamos a dividir todo entre -20
para que la "x" quede solita
como nos gusta,
sin embargo
¿Qué es lo que sabemos?
Que si dividimos entre un número negativo,
tenemos que invertir la desigualdad
entonces tenemos
-20x sobre -20
aquí... ahorita digo qué pasa
y esto es -2 entre -20
y la desigualdad se tiene que cambiar,
se tiene que cambiar de mayor o igual,
a menor o igual.
Entonces esto ya se cancela y me queda "x"
menor o igual que...
menos entre menos es más,
y 2 entre 20 eso son 1 sobre 10,
es 1/10.
En términos de notaciones de
de intervalos,
pues empezamos en un décimo
y éste sí lo incluimos,
por eso ponemos este tipo de límite ¿verdad?
y
nos vamos hacia abajo
hasta el menos infinito abierto.
Muy bien,
ya nada más por diversión vamos a ver
qué pasa si lo graficamos,
por ejemplo aquí andará el 0,
por acá andará el 1
y quizás aquí ande el 1/10,
el 1/10
y me dice tómate el 1/10
y éste inclúyelo entonces,
rellenamos el circulito
y tomate todos los que son más chicos que él
y puedes intentarlo,
elige cualquier número más chiquito que 1/10
y verás que satisface la desigualdad.